hey guys it's justine and today we're
going to be chatting a little bit about
the new samsung galaxy s10 the s10e the
s10 plus and
the galaxy fold as a lot of you guys
know and i've probably seen in your
subscription feed everyone's been
posting of all the new samsung galaxy
that was announced this week in san
francisco and unfortunately i wasn't
able to make it to the event my family's
been in town so i wanted to stay and
hang out with them but a lot of you guys
were asking me justine which phone are
you going to get
and as many of you had guessed on
twitter i pre-ordered the white one
terabyte ceramic version so it's kind of
crazy because the total number of
configurations of phones that they
announced is i'm
actually well i'm not going to count it
but i think it's like over 30
which is a lot of phones so in the
galaxy lineup to start off they
announced the s10 which i feel like is
the mid-range
tier which most people will probably end
up getting above that is the s10 plus
and below those
is the s10e and above all of that i
guess it's sort of above all of that
because
it kind of has some upsides and some
downsides is the s10 5g
you may have already seen all of the
specs and some review videos and some
hands-on things but i don't have a
phone with me so i don't really have
anything to show you other than what
they announced at the press conference
if you didn't see it already which is a
quick rundown of some of the specs and
prices
as i said the s10 is their mid-range and
the starting price at 900
it features three rear cameras the first
one is a 16 megapixel ultra wide lens
and this looks incredible there's
something about just a wide angle lens
especially coming from a phone
that's amazing this one doesn't feature
optical image stabilization but the
other two lenses do
there's a 12 megapixel dual aperture and
a 12 megapixel telephoto which has 2x
optical zoom the front facing selfie
camera is 10 megapixels and it also
features the dual aperture function the
s10 comes in 128 or 512 gig options with
8 gigs of ram
you can also expand the storage with an
sd card up to 512 gigs
it has a 6.1 inch screen which is one of
the first to earn an
hdr 10 plus certification this is
basically samsung's version of dolby
vision as for colors so this is where i
shine even though i
would probably get the flamingo pink but
they don't have that one in a one
terabyte option that's why i opted for
the white ceramic also did i mention
that it has 12 gigs of ram
the ceramic what i fell to the floor
when i heard that so here's all of the
color options
there's a flamingo pink prism blue prism
black and the prism white
so the ceramic white and black is only
available in the 5 12 and 1 terabyte
options so if that is something that you
didn't want in the s10 plus
then you're gonna have to do the upgrade
which brings us to the s10 plus which
has a starting price of a thousand bucks
it has a 6.4 inch screen with a 4 100
milliamp battery whereas the s10
only has a 3 400 milliamp battery the
s10 plus has the same triple camera
setup as the s10 but it does have an
additional selfie camera on the front
which gives us the same 10 megapixel
selfie camera as on the s10 but this
other one is an 8 megapixel depth
sensing camera so this will give you
better front-facing portrait or depth
mode photos
like i had mentioned previously this
model does come in a one terabyte option
with 12 gigs of ram yes
you heard me correctly the 512 and the
one terabyte options are the ones that
can be configured
in the black or white ceramic obviously
it's completely unnecessary but
it's bare if you want it and if you
don't it also comes in a 128 and 512. i
think much like the ceramic apple watch
which was one of my favorite apple
watches ceramic does tend to be a little
bit heavier so i will be interested to
see
the weight difference between the
ceramic and just one of the regular
phones i love ceramic so i'm
extremely excited about this now this
brings us to the s10e which is the
lowest model
in this lineup the starting price for
this one is 750. it features a 5.8 inch
screen which is smaller than the
previous s9 the s10e
only has two cameras on the front so it
has the wide angle and the ultra wide so
if the telephoto is something that
you're interested in
this does not have it two other things
that this phone doesn't have that the
other two have
is a curved screen it also doesn't have
the in-screen fingerprint reader and
this is all new for samsung because it's
using this ultrasonic sensor technology
when you press your finger
on the screen it's using sound waves to
read your fingerprint the s10 does have
a fingerprint sensor but it's actually
on the power button which i think is
kind of an interesting placement because
you're usually going to be turning the
power button on and off anyway
so it seems like a very natural place to
put that then that brings us to another
phone this is the fourth option which is
not going to be available i think until
q2
which technically could be as early as
april in this 5g option
it'll be coming to verizon first and
then other carriers the screen size
on the 5d version is actually 6.7 inches
so that's
larger than the s10 plus which is 6.4
inches
another really cool thing about the 5g
version is it has four cameras
on the front like that's a lot of
cameras three of them
are the same as the s10 plus but it also
has this new 3d depth camera which is
not necessarily i feel like going to be
used to take photos
but i think it'll definitely help taking
portrait mode photos or even used in ar
applications
or filters or do people still use
snapchat i'm not
sure i still love snapchat filters don't
get me wrong it will be interesting to
see how they implement that in the
future since that is something that is
new i mean there's four freaking cameras
like
what are you gonna do i don't even know
this is just getting
out of hand and i love it
i am here for it i want 45 cameras i
want to have every single possible
option just give me
all of the lenses it also has the same
dual camera setup as the s10 plus it's
got that 8 megapixel depth sensing in
the 10 megapixel selfie camera it has a
ml amp battery and it comes in a 256 gig
storage option
but the thing about this is it doesn't
have expandable storage like some of the
other phones do
so if that was something that is
important to you then this may not be
the phone for you
but hey you're going to have 5g speeds
you're going to have
six total cameras to just get wild
sacrifices have to be made
and i think that's probably i don't know
i really love having an sd card i'm not
going to lie
even though my iphone doesn't have an sd
card option being able to transfer files
and photos from my phone to my computer
the sd card is always so incredible and
last but not least
the galaxy fold this is so incredible
because
one of the things that a lot of people
were saying online is it's so expensive
it's this it's that shh
calm yourself this is something that is
not for everyone this is sort of a
concept brought to life
and it's available for us to try it out
like this is honestly something that i
think is still super early
i don't think it's going to be the best
version of what the future of this is
going
to look like i mean having a foldable
display i mean this really does
kind of open up a wide range of
possibilities especially for developers
that's one of the things that i'm going
to be really interested to see is how
are developers going to take advantage
of this like what kind of cool things
can they come up with that haven't been
created already because you couldn't
fold your phone
so a little bit of the specs on this
thing is it has a 4.6
inch display when it's folded and when
it's unfolded it has a 7.3 inch display
this is supposed to be available in late
april and the starting price is one
thousand
nine hundred and eighty dollars which
yes is a lot of money but like i said
this is not something that everyone is
going to buy that everyone is going to
need
it is something that is kind of pushing
the envelope showing people that this is
the next wave of where we're going is it
where we're going i
don't know i feel like it is it has 12
gigs of ram which is quite a lot but i
feel like it is a tablet so you will be
doing more on this than you would be say
on your phone it also has two batteries
so there's one on each side
it also has six total cameras much like
the 5g version it has the 12 megapixel
wide
12 megapixel telephoto and a 16
megapixel ultra wide
and then there's two on the inside it
has the 10 megapixel selfie camera
and the 8 megapixel depth sensing camera
there's just a lot of information
and are you guys even still there it
also has one more camera it's a 10
megapixel one that is on the front so
in whatever configuration this foldable
tablet is you'll be able to take a
picture it doesn't have an expandable sd
card option but it does have 512 gigs of
storage which i think is probably
perfectly fine
if all else fails you can just store
some stuff in the cloud which i feel
like most of you do anyway
one thing that it doesn't have which i
wish that it kind of did but i feel like
hey this thing folds let's not get too
crazy
it doesn't have the imprint ultrasonic
fingerprint reader but much like the
s10e
it has the fingerprint reader on the
power button so it's pretty easily
accessible
and i think the reason that they did
that is because they want you to be able
to have access to that
whether it's open or closed i feel like
if it was open or closed
you wouldn't be able to have the
fingerprint screen reader because
that'd probably make the phone even way
more expensive if you have two
ultrasonic fingerprint readers let's
just
calm down in the us this will be
available for at t
and t mobile customers first so that was
some of the announcements from this past
week and man the galaxy fold though it
is something that i'm
super hyped to check out because just
taking a screen
and folding it i feel like is going to
be so
satisfying like that's not something
that you're supposed to do
like the rollable lg tvs that they had
at ces that they actually
had in person this year that was
something that was sort of
a concept that we saw on stage or in
videos every samsung has been pushing
this concept i think for the past few
years at ces
so now that it is actually a real thing
that we can purchase and buy and have
in our home in our hands is pretty cool
i look forward to checking it out
again i ordered the ceramic white
version i'm so tempted to get the
flamingo pink because
it's just calling my name i don't know
we'll see
leave me a comment below if you think
that i should get the flamingo pink as
well or
do i not do i just need one phone i just
need one phone i don't need another
phone justine what are you doing do you
have a problem i have too many phones
thanks for watching let me know if you
guys have any other questions or
comments below i look forward to
checking out these phones and some more
fun phones that will be coming out
very very shortly this year is gonna get
so crazy so quick i can feel it
i'll see you later bye